hey everyone i'm lucy and welcome to
this week's episode of generation next
we've just finished watching the game
awards so we thought this week
we'd be talking all about brand new
games that'd be coming to
xbox series x and playstation 5. but
most importantly
we finally know what xbox's quadruple a
studio
is working on so before we delve into
that joining me today i've got xbox
expert jordan remain
what's up and playstation pro tomorrow
hussein hi everyone how's it going
how are you tam there was no elden ring
oh my god
you just poked them almost immediately
is that how it is we're just gonna like
on each other's days
real hard no i was oh lucy beck hasn't
released any albums lately that sucks
i mean actually last year he released an
album so
he's also in a new uh he's in a new
music video with the strokes
all right we get it back is doing things
like he's just sitting around
he's prolific uh yeah so no elden ring
um yeah what's he
greg gets it greg understands
thank you for your support trending
gamer of 1996.
let's get into the show get into the
show
so a pretty great show overall lots of
world premiere uh to dig into but let's
kick off with the big one
god it feels like years since
the initiative was formed uh they've
been
kind of called xbox's quadruple a
studio which i don't even know what that
means
i don't even know well it means it's a
aaa studio but they've got
a lot more money than most aaa studios
because
big phil is there just being like blank
check let's do what you want
is that what all the a's mean it's just
money yeah sponsoring away
yeah uh so yeah the initiative uh
it's a i think they're down in santa
monica they're in l.a based studio
uh filled with prestigious gaming
uh development talent so it's helmed by
daryl gallia
who's ex-ceo of crystal dynamics you may
know crystal dynamics as being the
developer behind
tomb raider and the avengers
game kate bishop out this week
uh we're held by jared galga and then
you've got other people you've got
people from bungie
you've got of course crystal dynamics uh
destiny 2's
narrative designer uh is now working uh
over there
and we finally know what they're working
on and that's perfect dark
no surprise there yeah i think we've
actually talked about it because they um
we did talk about this because uh they
registered the perfect dark
uh twitter handle months ago the same
time they did the fable thing
uh but then unfortunately it looks like
someone is squatting on it
because i went to go have a look and
it's currently not a perfect dark at all
do you know who's squatting on it that's
a look twitter.com
tomorrow it's me
phil if you want it give me a call
it's someone called jose benitez yes
that is my name
uh he's his bio is in spanish and he's a
lover of music cinema technology and all
those things that give meaning to life
yeah dislikes perfect dark perfect dog
i mean let's talk about it like of all
of the
xbox franchises to reboot taking
something from rare
and giving it to a brand new studio do
you think that's risky uh
i don't think so i think like um
i think like that it matters what the
team is right like microsoft are very
open to doing that they've done it with
fable they took it from lionhead and
have given it to playground and
it's just a trust in the project i mean
the choices are either
use it or lose not really lose it but
like just let it fester and if it puts
use it or uh renew the trademark every
few years so
people think you're still gonna use it
use it but not enough to realize that
dude is squatting on your twin
um but yeah i i don't think i've got any
issues with it like the the talent that
they've put together you know
ex crystal dynamics who as looks you
said before
are known for being the studio behind
the legacy of kane soul river
um so like good team there
they've got basically a blank canvas
like joanna dark they clearly are
bringing back
eco eco kind of like terror not
eco-terrorism but like
and kind of like weirdly
ecological vibe to it that they're
looking at yeah so that's
that's kind of interesting and different
um it's
kind of futuristic which means that gun
that as you shoot for the walls is
probably going to be back and everyone's
going to be
absolutely livid about it in multiplayer
so uh there you go yeah i say it's
always cool when a studio is allowed to
try their hand at someone else's work
like with arcane with prey
and i guess you could say ubisoft with
the
mario kart mario characters with mario
and rabbits
coalition with gears yeah yeah
like i wonder if it's gonna become
another coalition studio where it's like
a situation where it's you know like
this one studio owns
this particular franchise or if maybe
uh perfect dark is gonna be like just
the springboard
for how xbox are to be making games in
the future because i mean
the phrase quadruple a right now
is just is just very buzz wordy but i do
wonder if it's something
i don't know if it's a new way they're
approaching actual like development of
their games
which is how much money perfect dark
makes when it comes out
okay so it's not just the initiatives
new project that we'll be talking about
obviously we want to hit on
some more uh next gen games that were
shown off at the game awards
uh very excitingly the uh console port
of disco elysium for example at two or
three month exclusivity on playstation
which is wild
but that will be coming to kind of
current and next-gen
consoles next year um but let's talk
about the callisto protocol
oh man it looks super spooky
i am so in god
the moment i that character woke up and
it was like something on the back of the
neck i was like
all right they're going for the back of
the neck health indicator thing very
dead space you're into it
yeah nice it's about time someone did
that again
um yeah that that came glenn schofield
um no relation to philip no from
narration to philip schofield
thankfully geez um but what they're
called striking distance studios
um former ea folks the team
a lot of the minds behind dead space um
putting together a game which is not
called dead space
no but it looks but it looks a lot like
it
so uh the callisto protocols
that's an interesting name like callisto
yeah yeah
callisto maybe it actually means
something to people who play
pub g since it's in that universe i was
gonna say let's talk about the big thing
that no one's talking about
really so much yet uh is that it's set
in the pubg universe
i expanded i have figured this out
there's gonna be a point
where you find just a pan and use it to
block a bullet
and that's how they justify it that's it
that's how glenn schofield was like
how do we get the pubg money and then
someone goes just put a pan in the game
and you're like all right
well no you know how isaac was like an
unwilling
engineer maybe the protagonist and this
is just like an unwilling chef
and that's why he's not an
imagine this is what happens like you
start the game you're in a chopper
you have to jump out of the plane onto
the island and it's just
a normal game of pubg and you have to
keep doing that until you win
but when you win they put you in a
rocket and fire you into space
and then you just wake up on the space
station you're like
what the hell and then the callisto
protocol begins
that would be super cool i'm very
excited to see how it
i mean how it's set in the pubg universe
at all
um but yeah they they also have a really
great blurb
um it's like there's a story driven
single-player survival horror game
from the creators of dead space so it's
like basically all of these buzzwords
it's just didn't
all this marketing speak in one line but
then uh glenn schofield's a little
interview the game was
like we just want to make the scariest
game ever made
i want to make you yourself
so i'm very excited about that one uh
but other games on the list uh let's
talk
arc two no no
i which i assume will be coming to next
gen gotta say the name
the past and the furious look i
am so are the other ones i'm so annoyed
that i wasted my joke on a reply
tweet um because i said i hoped that it
would star
dwayne turruck johnson
uh difficult to say i kept wanting to
say dwayne the rock but
so i think the past and the furious the
first person i saw do that was ben pack
um and then my one was uh horizon diesel
dawn
um that's really good so i think i think
we should like call it that not arc too
because
okay let's go to horizon uh diesel dawn
okay i mean
it's weird talking about arc on a game
on a show where we're talking about you
know the
power and potential of next-gen because
arc is one of the
buggiest games i have ever played and
it's still really bucky
like i know it's been it's been out for
a while i don't know if it's
like i haven't played it in actually a
couple years
but yeah i remember being like the
buggiest thing i've ever played oh yeah
so i'm
i'm hoping that like for this sequel
they've got that [ __ ] locked down
and i really really want to know how
much vin diesel is going to be in it
i hope he's in it but if he's the main
character to help you play
as vin diesel i hope he just never
leaves like even when he's like okay
i'll see you later he just follows you
constantly
he's like the the curse from it follows
he's just always there
you're gonna play as the daughter and
just explore the world and every once in
a while he's just gonna pop out of a
tree and like throw an axe at someone
sneaking up on you
god uh i would say that would that was
one of the biggest surprises of the
night uh but we also had
um flight sim is coming to
we knew it would be coming to consoles
eventually but next summer
for series x i'm very intrigued about
that one because
it looks incredible but it also seems
like it's super super intensive on the
pc
so i do wonder how the series x is gonna
fare
optimize it
so actually next next year is looking
really great
for xbox you've got the medium in
january you've got flight sim
in the summer and then of course going
to talk about it
halo we finally got
well they kind of delayed it into 2021
and then they've now said that it's uh
it's fall 2021 so what do we think about
the delay
did we expect it to be that long no
but it's it could be cool if they delay
it to november and it comes out on the
20th anniversary
of combat evolved i i kind of dig that i
love games that come out on like the
anniversaries of their first one but
i love that honestly yeah they posted
the blog post at 3 43 in the afternoon
i love stuff like that so if you want to
delay it to november
yes it's like snoop dogg he always
releases his songs at 4 20.
does he actually i don't think that's
true
oh i'm so gullible i think i've done
that like three times to you this week
yeah but like yeah i think like i think
we talked about it on
uh hit video game podcast gamespot after
dark i'm
the fact that it's so far away is kind
of gives me some confidence
like they've clearly looked there and go
we need gone we need a lot of time to
make we need to work on this
yeah so so they've been given a lot of
time which is fantastic love to see it
i found the blog post very reassuring in
how
they were being transparent
they explained craig's stupid face hey
like
just don't say words about my book i
love craig play his face is clearly
stupid in that picture
they were like yeah his face looks
stupid it's cause we never finished his
stupid face
that's why because he was never his
stupid face was never supposed to be
it was never so they were like no one
will ever look at this on a frame by
frame
level never just put a stupid face in it
and then the first thing
people did was like frame by frame the
gamers came along
look you joke about frame by frame but i
literally
um i mean let's talk about the biggest
if i say for the next game
in the next game is uh i i looked at
mass effects
pretty pretty intently and then i i
goofed because
um i've never seen a red war of the
world and i was like
really intrigued by the war of the
worlds quote that's in the trailer i
just tweeted it i was like
hey what about these 200 years in
between the start of the 20th century
and then someone was like that's from
more of the world so i had to own up to
that one
but next time the book
thank you i said i said i've never read
or watched or listen to the radio
version so i'm i'm actually like looking
at the books now and being like i could
just download all of these and read them
yeah i'm kind of i'm kind of into it
maybe i'll do that
just getting books just getting mass
effect books and
readings oh mass effect oh absolutely do
it i have so
many tam they're all good dude well i uh
what's that book that got um
like it introduced kai lang for the
first time and he was eating cereal
and the book was like very very torn
apart by the community
yeah that one actually isn't all that
good that one's not great but the other
ones are good
anyways let's talk about mass effect is
back i like how they went with mass
effect will return
and as if like they haven't already said
that five times i was like
it's like yeah we know we get it yeah we
know
looking at mike gamble's uh linkedin
profile
i haven't really but he has been working
on it like we know that they have
look the words give me serotonin and i
love that okay
i mean honestly like today was such a
great day to be a bioware fan because
not only was that mass effect but there
was dragon age 2
and i'm not in any way saying that
either of these games are going to come
out in 2021 like we know we're getting
mass effect remasters in 2021
who knows about the other two but it
makes me
really excited to be a bioware fan again
yeah super curious news to
hear after the departures from bioware
but
also like excited to see what people are
working on
for dragon age and mass effect i
i really hope that so like obviously
andromeda and inquisition were made in
frostbite
and it was very much you could tell like
the team wasn't necessarily quite sure
how to make
a third-person game work in frostbite
but i guess that now that they've had so
much more time with that
engine and now we've got the power of
next-gen i'm really excited to see what
next-gen mass effect in dragon age can
look like
there's always been so much potential
there with like um
biotic effects and magic effects and i
just think that would be really cool
yeah please let us have it i'm like
really i'm really excited for like
it's like you said like it's a great
time to be a mass effect or dragon age
fan but like between the
remasters and then this
let's go so we didn't really see
anything from uh like kind of
playstation tent polls that we know are
coming next year like god of war sequel
horizon forbidden west but we did see a
release date
uh for returnal uh which also psyched me
out because
they started with a first-person
viewpoint of a white door
um and i was like god is it pt
because the power of jeff managed to
like has he texted some people and he's
just got it back uh but no
i am i'm excited about return because i
really like uh house mark as a studio
um but not a huge showing
from sony really um beyond what's the
other game
season um yeah that looks cool it does
look cool yeah but sony admittedly has
already done a pretty good job
letting us know what's coming from their
studios
in the near future i think sony
now that i think they've got the kind of
cadence down and the rhythm down of
doing their own showcases i think
microsoft do too
but i think microsoft never really shy
away from a big event like a game awards
like they will they know that you know
they get more eyes there they get
they get an extra audience who might
necessarily be tuning in to watching
xbox broadcast
because it's just xbox right they can
reach other people whereas sony i think
maybe
i just like if we build it
they will come they will come people now
know that you can
get pretty much the entire yakuza
franchise on xbox game pass
absolutely loves to see it i mean you
can get yakuza and game pass you can get
master chief on playstation and kratos
on xbox now
the whole damn world's gone topsy-turvy
but
sorry so this is uh we've just been
covering a large show for like the last
four hours um but we wanted to do a
quick episode of gen x talking about
uh kind of like the future of gaming so
thank you for watching us and let us
know what your favorite trailer
from the game awards has been and next
week we'll be back
talking about whether ps5 and xbox
series x issues
have been fixed and all the improvements
we've seen come to the brand new
consoles
because it's just been about a month
since they released all right
see you then bye